hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching the original 1979
Muppet movie I've never seen a Muppet
movie I haven't seen pirate treasure
island I haven't seen the one with Tina
Fey I haven't seen the Christmas Carol I
haven't seen any of the Muppet movies I
grew up watching the animated Muppets on
television does that count
I don't know I never really wanted to
see them because it just seems like like
kind of kids kind of babyish but I saw
Blues Brothers 2000 last week I feel
like this is gonna be a breath of fresh
air there has to be some redeeming
quality about it I'm wondering there's
gonna be comedy and then I'm wondering I
don't know is it just like so sweet that
people love it because I'm into back I
saw the mr. Rogers documentary so I've
got my my green top on and I'm ready to
go
let's do it Kermit the Frog
[Music]
you
oh my gosh I loved that I loved the
comedy I loved these like genuineness it
was just very like sweet and wholesome
and pure and also in that extremely
entertaining and funny and the puppetry
was incredible and I loved it connection
I love the fourth wall breaking in this
it starts off right off the bat they're
all the Muppets are in this theater and
they're getting ready to watch the
muffin movie and how the month it's
named and in the middle of the film of
the film kind of messes up and so you're
back in with them in the theater and and
then at the end of course they're all
there it's it's really great though the
critics are there and everyone that you
know and love is there and it's a great
way to start it off also Fozzie Bear has
to slide where he's like I'm so nervous
if I'm not funny I won't be able to live
with myself and my god if that's not
just the biggest mood and it's so sweet
it's still really people Oh God that one
got me in my heart what's left of it
it's me after every NZ episode is
released onto the Internet
oh my god I'm so nervous if I'm not
funny I'm hoping to live with myself I
wrote oh it is so awkward though
seeing Kermit with Miss Piggy after all
the drama that went down a couple years
back was that one when they broke up he
has a new girlfriend then Kermit is
inside the swamp the lake wherever he's
at he's playing his little banjo and
it's so sweet read my lips a league
eight or so for some reason there's this
Hollywood agent in the swamp with Kermit
and he's like I gotta catch a plane how
do I get there kermit get some great
directions it also tells him to look out
for alligators and then probably an
agent is like you should come to
Hollywood you've got what it takes
it's like obviously he does he's
wonderful that's really where the story
goes from he wants to go to Hollywood
and and give people joy in performance
just so sweet
also very relatable lots are relatable
thanks to this movie and then he finds
friends to bring along with him I didn't
realize this I was watching with someone
and and they told me the puppeteer had
to be under water for that first scene
it's amazing also he's going home to
prepare for his Hollywood journey and
he's on a bicycle and that's like how
did they do that how did they do that
see is made in 79 which again it looks
better than a lot of the films I've seen
recently in the past the puppetry is so
so so so good so well done and it looks
like a movie from 79 oh god I love
Fozzie so much it's not staged he's not
doing very well people are upset at him
and he's like I'm trying so hard and my
god
but before they go out they're stopped
by this man who owns a frog legs company
and wants Kermit to be the face of it
just like that he's the villain of the
film
really it's an adorable villain they run
into a band that paints their car and
Fozzie's like I don't know how to thank
you and Kermit's like I don't know why
to thank you did he meet a lot of people
like right off the bat you meet gonzo
which her a love gonzo we picked up a
weirdo you meet jack who you feel so bad
for then you've got the introduction to
Miss Piggy falling in love with Kermit
and it's so good she wins a beauty
pageant
of course she's Miss Piggy and then she
sees him across the room and has like
this whole montage in her head of her
doing romantic things with Kermit the
Frog it's just like when I had met Ike
for the first time one thing I heard
about before watching the movie is
there's a lot of 70s star cameos and I
was a little concerned that I wasn't
gonna see any of them or notice any of
them because I don't know who people are
hi my name's Tamara chambers I don't
know who anyone is and so when I saw
people that I recognized I got very
excited Richard Pryor I actually know
who that is
can you believe it also noticed Steve
Martin again I know who that is
Wow oh then you see Mel Brooks another
person then I know I don't have a album
of his but I know him I know things
good job Tamara Thank You Tamara you're
welcome girl
so basically the rest of the movie is
just kind of them going along them
getting oiled by the villain of the
movie and then then making it to
Hollywood Miss Piggy there's just scene
where she has a new dress on they're
gonna go out on a date she's a bit pushy
but you know what take what you want
well no don't take what you want ask for
it first be mindful of people but your
dress can get in then she leaves to do a
commercial and this is a really weird
plot point because she's like alright I
just got you free and I love you so much
hello agent oh there's a commercial
alright goodbye everyone which that's
not the weird part I understand that get
your money while you can girl I get it
but then Kermit's like really sad and
depressed he's like I love her and she
left me about this stuff but then like
five minutes later they see her just
like down the road and she's like
hitchhiking she gets in the car just
like so what just happened since I last
saw you then they never speak about a
pigpen why didn't you do that that was
kinda weird okay their car breaks down
and they're like alright I just I guess
we won't be famous then they sing it's
very relatable I don't know why that
part specifically but it is then the
band picks them up and all is well
they're headed to LA and it's just it
was really sweet and kind hearted and
this made me realize that I do not watch
a lot of kind-hearted films then there's
one more thing before they get to
Hollywood they have to have a showdown
with the villain and Kermit is gonna
have this showdown because quote he's
not gonna spend his life running away
from a bully
and then they make it to LA that's it's
so wonderful you're going to paint
yourself green and test how easy or not
easy it is being green
no only because I did that recently in a
video and it was not easy you'll wonder
why the Billboard was so detailed but it
actually had a cream pie on it I mean
what poor free samples on the side of
the road I did when that happened I was
like back when billboards were good no
almost be sick of saying hey it's that
one guy haha you know me too well
I didn't recognize I think most of the
cameos even if I didn't know what they
were from specifically I was like you're
from something I know that Italy
I predict that someday you'll find it
The Rainbow Connection the lovers the
Genny nearly women I don't know why I
keep adding that ending you'll be
surprised to see Steve Martin in shorts
and slightly darker hair I was no fit
right in his book is my favorite book of
all time foreign standing up for like
six times he talks a lot about his hair
changing colors I saw that movie twice
when it was released I thought it was
pure magic at the time I think it still
is I think it held up surprisingly well
and it was so delightful and something
that I want to rewatch thank you so much
for watching and I will see you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
you